[Música]
alguna vez se preguntaron la importancia
que puede tener la escucha de un otro en
la vida de una persona
esta pregunta que surgió tratando de
encontrar una idea para desarrollar e
inmediatamente pensé en la concreción de
los deseos y como muchas veces esos
deseos
se pueden concretar gracias a las buenas
escuchas de otras personas
yo nací en bernal provincia de buenos
aires
en el año 2009 44 después tras recordar
rusia
cuando tenía ocho años
le pedí a mi mamá que quería estudiar el
piano
así es qué
mi madre me tomo de la mano y
silenciosamente dado que ella era una
mujer de pocas palabras me llevó dos
cuadras hasta la profesora del barrio y
ahí empecé a estudiar el piano me
acuerdo que tenía que ir todas las
tardes una hora porque mi casa no tenía
instrumento
entonces éste
estaba allí estudiando una hora de será
un espacio maravilloso para mí porque de
alguna manera me permitía como
abstraerme de una realidad que no me era
demasiado grata
pasó un tiempo y mi madre resuelve
mudarse a la capital para estar cerca de
su familia de sus hermanas
y entonces nos mudamos y el piano ya
quedó en bernal de estudiarlo pero los
14 años le pedí a mi mamá nuevamente
aquella fue una gran escucha que mi mamá
me pudiera llevar a lo de la profesora
de piano y ahora de vuelvo a pedir a los
14 años que quería estudiar el clarinete
y les cuento que por esos tiempos yo ya
estaba en la escuela secundaria y ya
había cursado el primer año con alguna
dificultad y en mi segundo año y va para
peor al punto tal que me lleve ocho más
de diez y lo repetía
y claro eso ahora pienso cualquier madre
esas circunstancias frente a un pedido
de un hijo le hubiera dicho acoso de
porquería ponerte a estudiar y hasta que
no pase de años no te compro nada sin
embargo ella me escuchó nuevamente y me
llevó hasta un negocio que estaba en la
calle gascón de compraventa de
instrumentos usados un negocio muy
pequeñito y me compró un clarinete que
era muy rudimentario
ni siquiera tenía estuche pero me
acuerdo cuando salimos del negocio ella
compró un pedazo de tela y me tejió me
escogió una funda así que yo ya tenía mi
clarinete
y no sólo eso sino que además me llevo a
lo de un profesor y pude empezar a
estudiar esta sin duda fue la gran
escucha de alguien en mi vida no mi
madre supo escucharme y llevarme a un
lugar y proveer me de alguna manera de
una herramienta que me acompañó a toda
la vida y que me dio las posibilidades
de forjar un futuro y de tener la
felicidad de tocar música
profesionalmente
había que trabajar porque mi madre
estaba enferma tenía una pensión muy
precaria así que me pasé a la nocturna y
empecé a trabajar un tío me consiguió
un empleo en ibm ibm la empresa de
computación para un joven entrar en ibm
era como tener el futuro asegurado eran
los albores de la computación así es que
empecé a trabajar en ibm y cuando empecé
a trabajar
me junté un poco de dinero y me compré
un saxo que también era bastante
precario pero empecé a estudiar el saxo
motivado por el jazz moderno que tanto
me gustaba en ese tiempo
me acuerdo qué
y van mucho escuchar jazz a la noche
faltaba de escuela oa veces cuando salía
de la escuela me iba a los boliches
donde se tocaba ya donde había músicos
tocando ese mundo me apasionaba lo
cierto es que me acostaba tarde me
levantaba tarde y llegaba tarde al
trabajo me acuerdo que la tarjeta mina
de asistencia estaba toda roja y ya
tenía ya había tenido varios
apercibimientos por parte de antonioni
que así se llamaba el gerente de
administración de ventas persona que
pese a esos este apercibimientos me
quedaría muy bien muy gratamente total
que en esos tiempos empecé a tocar a
tocar jazz
que era mi pasión en esos tiempos y en
un punto lo sigue siendo claro es tanto
una vez
[Música]
pero
[Aplausos]
m
gracias me acuerdo que por esos días me
vinieron a buscar unos muchachos del
barrio de palermo que querían armar un
grupo de rock y querían poner un saxo
así es que
tuve una cierta resistencia pero por
último me convencieron y fui empezamos a
ensayar y el grupo empezó a sonar
realmente bien y los domingos los
domingos al mediodía había un programa
que se llamaba escala musical la
televisión en blanco y negro todavía
había muy pocos canales tal vez dos o
tres
los domingos al mediodía canal 13 escala
musical lo veía todo el mundo así que
dimos una prueba y entramos y empezamos
a tocar ahí lo cierto es que
un lunes llegó al trabajo
y una compañera me dice che pibito te
llama antonio ni así es que yo ahí fui a
la oficina de antonioni pensando que me
iba a volver
recriminar desde
mi conducta y entonces llegó a la
oficina estaba la puerta abierta y ahí
lo veo antonio en su
escritorio de gerente y me dice pase
fase barack pase siéntese póngase cómodo
y entonces yo entré tímidamente y me
senté
yo en ese tiempo era bastante tímido e
introvertido y entonces me dice barack
lo estuve viendo ayer en el programa
escala musical muy bien me dice lo
felicito la verdad que no sabía que
tocaba también la verdad que me
sorprendió y muy bien su grupo era muy
bien suena muy bien y lo que más me
llamó la atención me dice es que lo
vistan contento
se lo veía feliz
y quiere queremos la cosa acá no lo veo
así
así que lo voy a despedir
y mejor
para mí fue como si me hubieran echado
un baldazo de agua helada encima porque
eran tiempos difíciles y en general los
muchachos que trabajábamos de clase
media clase baja era típico que cuando
uno cobraba el sobre por qué no había
depósito bancaria nada ellos les daban
un sobre con la plata entonces uno
agarraba el sobre y lo llevaba a la casa
y se lo daba a la familia después la
familia le daba para sus gastos
tal es así que me pasé como un mes
yéndome de mi casa sin decirle nada a mi
vieja me iba a la mañana temprano
haciendo de cuenta que me iba a trabajar
y me iba a casa de un amigo andaba por
ahí babeando pero no me animaba
lógicamente esto no podía continuar en
el tiempo demasiado así es que un buen
día
respire hondo y le dije a mi vieja lo
que había pasado
a partir de ese momento me encerré
estudiar
horas y horas el saxo y no pasó mucho
tiempo
que me golpea en la puerta de mi casa
voy a atender abro y hay un señor mayor
que me dice por eso fernando no le digo
sí y me dice me extiende la mano y se
presenta yo soy mariona con el
representante de jackie y los ciclones
ya que los ciclones ya quiero un
cantante que en esos tiempos grababan la
cbs y vendía una cantidad de discos
impresionantes y tenía muchísimo trabajo
y entonces este hombre me dice te
estuvimos escuchando en la escala
musical
y queremos que formes parte del grupo y
tenemos 15 días para que prepares el
repertorio y salimos en 15 días a hacer
una gira de 45 días por toda la
provincia de santa fe y parte de córdoba
vamos a tocar todos los días menos lunes
imagínense un trabajo increíble por
supuesto inmediatamente le dije que sí y
ahí caí en la cuenta que de repente y
sin quererlo casi me convertí en un
profesional de la música lo cierto es
que cuando volví en esa gira de 45 días
muy intensa muy intensa realmente
y volví a casa con una cantidad de plata
que ni yo lo podía querer era como si me
hubieran pagado ocho sueldos de ibm y
entonces este imagínense mi vieja como
estaba de contenta
y entonces me fui a una casa de música
que vendían estos saxos los elmer que
son instrumentos franceses los mejores
saxos y me acuerdo que inició un crédito
para comprarme uno
lo gracioso no esta cosa mediana y es
que uno tenía en esos años de juventud
yo tenía un tenía muchos discos y
admiraba muchísimo a un saxofonista
negro y lo sigo admirando para mí es el
máximo que se llamó john coltrane y
tenía un disco de john coltrane
que estaba en la tapa con sus actos con
un traje entonces yo me fui con la tapa
del vinilo a los desastres y le dije
señor quiere que quiero que me haga un
traje como éste
tal vez en estos tiempos pensaba que
ponerse va a tocar como con tres cosas
ya no sucedió nunca
[Música]
la escucha no como antonio ni pudo ver
me pudo escucharme y pudo casi desde el
lugar del padre que no tenía decirme voz
acá no tienen nada que hacer tu camino
es aquel así que lo recuerdo también con
un gran aprecio
bueno después vino sandro vino de
leonardo favio después armamos una banda
que se llamaba alma y vida que ahora de
paso les cuento que estamos tocando
nuevamente cuando éste nos deja salir
del geriátrico allá vamos a tocarlos
y después toque un año por la banda
spinetta por el flaco maravilloso
después armamos un grupo que se llamó
con el negro rada que se llamó la banda
y en el año 80 y en la década del 80
de alguna manera sentí como la necesidad
de conectarme con una música que se
escapara de lo anglosajón y armamos con
varas barrué con dúo medio tanguero y
después el trío vitale varias gonzález
donde tocábamos música argentina voy a
tocar un fragmento de un tema de astor
piazzolla
[Música]
e
a 9
[Música]
[Aplausos]
m
[Música]
amén
e
[Música]
[Risas]
e
[Aplausos]
pero no
[Música]
anime
e
[Música]
amor
bueno por último les cuento que en esta
última etapa de mi vida
desde hace ya 67 años por ahí este mi
deseo se instaló en un lugar que no era
hasta ese momento habitual en mí que era
la posibilidad de cantar y me puse a
componer temas tangos y canciones me
acuerdo qué
y me puse estudiar canto me acuerdo que
tenía una pareja en ese momento que me
decía barack para qué vas a cantar si
cantando esos 16 y tocando sos un 10
mejor dedícate a tocar e invitar tantos
cantantes conocidos importantes que
tenés amigos tuyos para que cantes estos
temas y vos tocaba algo estaba fallando
en la escucha en ese momento
y
lo curioso es que grabé por último ese
disco tocando el piano y cantando con
otros músicos invitados y tuve la suerte
de que en el año 2016 ese disco saliera
nominado en la terna para mejor este
disco de tango del año
pedazo de barrio
allá
[Música]
durmiendo salvos
perra
farol balanceando la barrera
y el misterio de dios que siempre
un ladrido de perros a la luna el amor
escondido en un corto
los ajos redoblando la laguna
y a lo lejos la voz del bandoneón
barrio de tango
lo une misterio
calles lejos más como estarán viejos
amigos que hoy ni recuerdo
que se habrán hecho dónde andará
barrio de tango que fue de aquella
juana la
que tanto amén
sabrá que sufro pensando en ella
desde la tarde
en que la deje
barrio de tango eluney misterio
desde el recuerdo te voy poder
bueno le escuchas la escucha no
la compresión de los deseos y la escucha
del otro
esta escucha que necesariamente
tan importante en muchas veces y que
necesariamente
tiene que ser una escucha que no tenga
prejuicios siempre conceptos una escucha
amorosa y a corazón abierto sin lugar a
dudas así es que muchas gracias por
escucharme
[Aplausos]
[Música]